guys there's a war of sorts on the
horizon for csgo and I'm not talking
about T's or cts or bomb plants or even
team rivalries I'm talking about csgo
eSports inexorable crawl towards global
circuits and franchise leagues in 2020
we have multiple major leagues competing
against each other two of which seem to
be going directly head-to-head in a war
for eyeballs for team participation and
at the end of the day for their very
survival and this weekend
the opening shots in that war were fired
okay so as far as csgo is concerned this
weekend was insane and if you've been
left in the words of Anders confused and
dazed well you're not the only one
Smith's looking confused and dazed
information has been coming fast and
furious the problem is it's been coming
from unnamed sources from offhand tweets
by individuals from three hour-long
podcasts and for the average csgo fan
it's just a little much to follow he'll
by all accounts a lot of the teams don't
know what's going on you're being asked
all these things I just don't know like
I'm hearing like this format may change
like what's the format that you guys
gonna have very you're gonna hold the
damn league like we're gonna take place
like you hear all these things but you
do not know for sure so that was faze
clan coach Yankel pound ovitch on the
hltv confirmed podcast so let's take a
deep breath and go over everything we
think we know so far it seems like in
2020 we're gonna have three different
Tio's that operate three different
leagues or circuits that will be in some
way in competition with each other for
tea participation for eyeballs your
eyeballs and therefore for success and
for survival so who are they well first
there's blast premiere in 2020 blast has
a much more coherent circuit than it has
in past years that's gonna all culminate
in a global final with a total prize
pool of 4.3 million dollars over two
seasons of spring it'll fall now last
year as you guys will remember it was
blast that was catching a lot of heat
for creating scheduling conflicts with
other TOS
it resulted in certain teams skipping
certain other events presumably for
blast events but let's Lee blast aside
for now because in 2020 the real
conflict seems to be shaping up between
ESL's completely revamped and
reconstituted Pro Tour which includes
the Pro League and the face it operated
or face it produced B site League both
leagues are reportedly slated to start
their spring season in March overlapping
with one another meaning they'll be in
direct competition as far as B site is
concerned first of all that name is a
placeholder so don't expect it to
actually be called that but over
we can we got some eye popping details
about it first of all it's gonna be
produced by face it who are killing
their previously ECS and it will have a
spring and a fall component there will
be a two million dollar Buy in to the B
site League if teams want to be part
owners of the league and unlock a
revenue sharing model this revenue
sharing model by the way according to B
site representatives is apparently more
lucrative than ESL's current revenue
sharing model again according to people
who work for V site now there will also
apparently be open qualifiers that allow
teams to get into the league and
circumvent that two million dollar
buy-in it will also mean though they
won't be part owners and they won't
share in that revenue sharing model
here's a big one
dan Pheidon president of cloud 9 said
that teams participating in the B site
League could be fined $100,000 per month
if they fall out of the top 20 teams in
the world now whether that's the hltv
top 20 or another third-party top 20
ranking we don't know yet he made those
comments during an interview with
eSports journalist Richard Lewis and
Duncan thorn shields the league can find
the teams if they fall out of the top 20
worldwide $100,000 a month this
proclamation is interesting to say the
least
especially given that it was Pheidon who
in a previous interview with DK talked
about how much money cloud 9 and other
teams lose on csgo the idea behind it
obviously is to make sure that the
league stays competitive despite being
franchised whether that's an incentive
for performance or just for not wanting
to be in the league well remains to be
seen as for Wi-Fi dan is talking about
all of this while he and his org are in
some way a founder or a leading
participant in B site exactly how I'm
not sure yet
it would probably be a good time to
mention that I'm in talks to try to
interview fight in for this show because
I got a lot of questions about B site
and his involvement in it he also said
it's worth noting that a lot of the
teams that will be involved in B site
will have us-based ownership finally
ESPN's jacob wolf reported over the
weekend
that there will be six initial
franchisees in the b-site league they
are cloud9 Genji Dignitas MIB are mad
lions and crazy now if this initial list
of teams is somewhat underwhelming to
you that's understandable
according to Thorin who is involved in
the production side and to Pheidon the
idea here is that their model their
revenue sharing system at b site will be
so attractive and lucrative that there
will be a pull of top-tier players or
top tier teams from ESL to B site
eventually as of this recording we have
no more confirmed details than those and
the talent lineup no location no
scheduled sparse details on the format
and no teams officially confirmed again
as of this report now while some of this
news about V site was breaking not to be
outdone ESL dropped their own bomb Pro
League season 11 will have 24 teams
pared down from 48 it's all on land the
finals are gonna culminate in an arena
and the grand finals will be a good old
best-of-five now you will notice some
pretty serious heavy hitters on this
list a straw louis faze clan hundred
thieves teamliquid
compare this to the prospective list of
franchisees in fee site and it looks a
little lopsided except that according to
DK again writing for DoubleTap and
citing unnamed sources most of those
teams haven't signed on yet they were
just invited another very controversial
part of this announcement was the
revelation that teams from last season
that didn't make it into this 24 teams
like big clan or Windigo or EU knighted
are just apparently [ __ ] out of luck and
will have to participate in the Mountain
Dew League now on Monday ulrich schultz
the senior vice president of product at
ESL apologized on behalf of ESL for how
the communication of this issue was
handled now it's really important to
note that at this point none of the tos
the tournaments or the circuits that
we've talked about blast b site ESL are
allowed to have explicit exclusivity
that means that none of these guys are
allowed to come out and say hey if you
play for our league you can't play for
the other guys this was ruled on in
black and white terms by valve last year
in a ruling called keeping things
competitive not being said that doesn't
mean that any team actually could play
in all of these leagues or circuits in
fact like I said at the beginning of
this video both be sites and the new
season of ESL pro league will start
their spring leagues in march
overlapping meaning effectively teams
will just have to pick one and honestly
who knows if valve will react to the
soft exclusivity play and throw a wrench
in everybody's machines it's worth
noting that the B site folks say they
have been in contact with valve for
quite some time now and everything is
above board but anyways what is the
actual difference between these two
leagues how could a team like faze clan
or straw Louis or Team Liquid or cloud 9
or whoever actually choose which to
participate in and which not to well
unfortunately because of the lack of
information released about both it's
pretty damn hard to tell now there's
plenty more to say on this subject even
now and as information starts to leak as
official announcements are made they'll
be way more to cram into our brains but
as it stands as of this recording that
is the long and short of the situation
at the beginning of 2024 csgo as for me
I'm currently trying to get cloud9
president dan Pheidon on this program to
talk about b-site league because i got a
lot of questions oppa card episode
wanted the card yes of course I watched
it little late to the game
honestly huge Star Trek fan we need
Captain Picard more than ever we need
heroes in this [ __ ] world to look up
to who are thoughtful who approach
problems with intelligence and kindness
who open their hands to enemies instead
of closing them as fists who create
drama without needing a gun in their
hand like we [ __ ] need [ __ ]
jean-luc [ __ ] Picard in 2020 ok
we need this this this [ __ ]